this position is white to play in check
mate 3 and again um I'm going to roll
through this now and get to one of the
most complicated positions that uh
should be memorized when you start with
the king in the opposite color corner of
the bishop um and try to give you some
principles along the way but you can
watch this video as many times as you
need to to get this pattern memorized so
this position as I said is white to play
in Checkmate and three if you haven't
paused your uh video and try to solve it
yourself then again that's a you problem
not a me problem I'm going to move ahead
Knight F5 King G8 Knight H6 check the
king back and the bishop delivers the
goods remember that in many cases the
Knight is the one relocating and putting
itself in a position to guard the light
squares in this case especially because
we have a dark Square Bishop if it was
the opposite if we had a light Square
Bishop often the Knight is we locating
itself to control the dark Square so
remember that first tip the Knight wants
to help control the opposite color
squares of the bishop so this position
is again a Checkmate three very common
climax where the Knight relocates and
eventually the bishop delivers the goods
okay in the next position you see here
we have a Checkmate in six moves we've
backed up the same pattern just a few
moves and if you move forward you see
that Black's last move King to G8 is
preparing to escape along the light
squares wouldn't be the end of the world
if you made a mistake and let it happen
because the king is already pretty much
trapped in the corner but the uh general
rule that you should remember is that
the king follows the knight's lead so
whenever the Knight has put itself on
the optimal Square usually the king is
close to follow lining itself up
directly with the knight in that case
they do work very well together
controlling the enemy King and keeping
him in a cage more more or less so this
position white plays King G6 makes a
waiting move with the
bishop and then takes away the square
forcing into the corner after King to h8
do you recognize this position it's the
same one we just did right one 2 3 check
that out from the position here after
the move King to G6 1 2 3 4 5 6 now what
we've done is is is simply back it up
only one move further it's a pretty
common setup to see the king and Knight
lined up in this way with the black king
preparing hopefully to run back to the
other side of the board in general the
best defensive strategy is to try to
stay away from the same color Corner as
the bishop unfortunately it's not really
something you can consider a strategy
because it's it's pretty much based on
whether or not your opponent messes up
if your opponent knows how to checkm
with the Knight and Bishop there's no
way the king can outplay the king in two
pieces but in this case white starts
with the move Knight to G7 again
remember we're getting to the same
pattern over and over controlling the
light squares and after the king moves
obviously we move into the exact
position with the King we highlighted on
the last position and the rest is pretty
much history the king moves back to f8
we make a waiting move with the bishop
to take away the square and thus force
him into the position of the corner
ending with the check main three note
that if the king had played King h8 it
doesn't make any difference because at
this point White's pattern to coordinate
his pieces into the right position is
not not based on anything black is doing
white can lead with the Knight first or
even make a bishop move first but after
the Knight moves and the bishop comes in
to take away the
square earlier we were making a waiting
move with the bishop with the King on f8
here we make a bishop move now as
obviously Knight H6 would be stalemate
that would be bad and after one simple
waiting move anywhere along this
diagonal would
work why completes the mating pattern
we've seen several times now what we're
going to do now that I've shown you sort
of the CL Max mating pattern that
consistently repeats itself we're going
to go to the beginning of a position
that I believe every chess player should
memorize um it it's the one that is
difficult and um really challenges is it
really challenges your knowledge of the
position because uh some of the patterns
are very counterintuitive meaning if you
haven't seen them or or practice before
they'd be very difficult to figure out
the first time that's what that little
phrase counterintuitive means so um
let's back up to the beginning
position and talk about uh a very famous
well-known pattern of the knights as
they push the king to the opposite color
Corner in this situation the king would
love to maintain itself in the opposite
corner of the bishop in order to to
avoid a force Checkmate if if white does
not know the following pattern that
we're about to do it's it's not possible
to force the Checkmate to the black king
you have to understand how to coordinate
your pieces and push him from one side
of the board to the other there's a
three-step process that I sort of
invented and I use with my students it
it Rhymes and I know that sounds silly
but I I think when things rhyme and it's
kind of fun to remember makes it easier
first thing we do is is remember that we
we have to use the bishop to take away
the dark squares of the king we don't
want to use our Knight to control the
same skolar squares as the bishop that's
wrong we want to use the Knight to
control the opposite color squares so
that they're both serving a purpose so
we make a waiting move and then take
away this Square from the king in order
to first start the process of pushing
him to the other side of the board now
start our three our three-step uh our
three-step phrase that we can use to to
remember how to do this first one is the
night leads the way the Knight leads
first whenever the king and Knight are
lined up remember that the Knight is the
first piece to improve itself if you
move the king first the black king would
simply go right back to where it once
was immediately threatened to remain it
on the light squares and and Whit's only
moved to to continue to make progress
would be to actually just come right
back with the King and and admit his
mistake so after the move King to d8 we
lead the way with the Knight Knight goes
first now again this is why it's
counterintuitive players who don't know
this position would would have a hard
time allowing this to happen because at
first glance it looks like your pieces
are completely uncoordinated with no
pattern existing in this position but
it's not true if the king chooses to run
which is what most players do the king
follow follows closely behind Okay so
the Knight leads the way and the phrase
I use with younger players is the king
Saves the Day meaning that he follows
follows the Knight he doesn't let the
Knight do the job on its own so after
the Knight leads the king is always the
next piece to move the king is always
the next piece to follow and when he
runs away our Knight takes a square that
actually again this pattern seems very
uncoordinated but the Knight is working
to guard light squares so that the
bishop can come all the way back and
complete the Box okay the bishop
delivers the goods that's the final step
so the king the Knight leads the way the
king saves the day and the bishop
delivers the goods just a fun way to
remember the bishop is always there in
the end to complete the Trap okay now
we're going to back up before we look at
this again and show you what would
happen on some of the more obvious moves
after the Knight leads the
way and the if the King was to repeat we
would have no problem the Knight would
simply check the king would save the day
and when he tried to go back you notice
this is actually the exact same
situation we had with the King and
Knight here the bishop would check take
the square and we could just rinse and
repeat this thing like shampoo and walk
the king over and notice that without
making any run he if he doesn't make any
any sort of run to try to escape then
our process is very simple and if you
recognize this position it's the one we
first started with check mate Uno do
Trace so again just memorize that that
that this initial position with the King
and Knight lined up and the Knight
guarding the light squares is very e if
the king attempts to remain on the back
rank the entire time our our our process
is very simple Knight leads the way we
take away this Square the king Saves the
Day staying with the Knight and when he
tries to stay on the dark squares the
bishop comes in and cleans up again this
process shouldn't be this is the easiest
one to to uh to recognize and and and
remember because black is not making any
direct challenge of White's approach so
again the hardest thing you learn is the
one we first did here where the where
the king actually tries to make an
attempt to run away with the move king
d8 and the key thing to remember here is
that the the step process I gave is
counterintuitive as looks to move the
king in this position when it seems like
all your pieces are completely
uncoordinated that's exactly what you
need to do the Knight led the way the
king Saves the Day preparing to protect
the square so that the Knight might come
in and guard light
squares and if the king went back we
would be exactly in the same pattern we
saw earlier where the Knight comes in to
guard the square the king would
eventually line up with the Knight and
the bishop would simply repeat the uh
the process of pushing the king over so
what we saw was that the king tries to
run regardless of what does we're
bringing the KN into this Square where
it guards the critical Escape uh routes
and the the most counterintuitive thing
to remember is this position here take a
good look at this position here and try
to uh try to tattoo it on your eyelid or
something so you see it every time you
close your eyes really memorize this one
okay and um and take it home because
it's the one that if you can remember
that the Knight and Bishop will
coordinate themselves well um as long as
the Knight is on the same color Square
as the bishop therefore guarding
opposite color squares if you can
remember this pattern then you can
figure it out over the board and now the
process of of completing it by by simply
getting into the corner is not hard he
moves the king we bring the bishop up
notice how well the the Knight and
Bishop work together he tries to escape
back we ignore it lining up the king and
Knight as we know is is is the right
thing to do and here can simply come
back taking away this Square notice
notice how the most important thing to
do is to keep the king and Knight in
optimal coordination and together
because the bishop
you know can can be left behind like it
was on A7 coming all the way back to E3
to guard critical squares here the
bishop is left behind but can quickly
guard a critical Square would need be
the bishop is a much easier piece to
bring in to like like I said deliver the
goods and clean up the position whereas
the knight and king really need to stay
together and and that that constantly
you know leading the way with the Knight
and then reining the king up with it is
is a really important pattern to to
remember so let's see how we finish this
one off we bring the bishop in Knight
leads the the way King saves the day if
he goes King H7 or King f8 in either
case we're bringing the Knight to
G7 in this case we would bring the
Knight to G7 both both cases were
guarding critical squares the bishop
would come in if the king had gone to E8
by the way or sorry
f8 we would have lined up the king and
the bishop would have come in this way
repeating the position we actually first
started with with an eventual obvious
Checkmate so we'll stick with this one
king H7 since we uh we haven't done that
way yet Knight G7 Bishop comes back line
up the king and rather than the the
first position where we saw the Knight
relocate to H6 here because the position
of the king is different we would simply
bring the Knight to f8 so that the
diagonal remains clear for the bishop to
deliver the goods take a good look at
that again again even though it looks
different it's the same Checkmate in
three Knight moves enters in Bishop
delivers the goods okay well that has
been a quick uh version of how to check
with a KN and Bishop and hopefully
that's some valuable material for you
guys here on chess.com YouTube channel
and hopefully we'll see you on the main
right on the main uh
site hope you enjoyed this video and
we'll see you around on chess.com